françois mitterrand évitant le pavillon
chinois premières informations forte de
cette visite du président de la
république au 38e salon aéronautique du
bourget une visite effectuée au pas de
course dans un salon qui suit le rythme
normal de l'industrie et qui cette année
est beaucoup plus civil que militaire
aérospatiale snecma d'assaut thompson
pour tous les grands industriels
français qui depuis longtemps pratique
les coopérations européennes
les carnets de commandes civiles sont
pleins ceux des commandes militaires
plus comme l exposition statique mais
surtout démonstrations en vol
françois mitterrand s'est fait présenter
la plupart des aéronefs français de
l'a320 au rafale en passant par la
spectaculaire démonstration de
l'hélicoptère de combat en terre le seul
capable d'effectuer un tonneau et
looping en emportant une charge
militaire importante démonstration
spectaculaire pour la cinquième visite
françois mitterrand bourget depuis 1981